j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
ce sens public volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour vous le savez on
cherche le plus souvent possible à le
faire des bas de société
consacrer ce soir à la crise du logement
la hausse des taux d'intérêt a fait
voler en éclat l'équilibre précaire du
secteur avant de détailler ce constat de
voir si la réponse du gouvernement et là
aussi à la hauteur des enjeux notre
reportage avec un couple qui a galéré
des mois avant de réussir à se loger
c'est signer Flora sauvages
après 5 mois de recherche active ce
jeune couple a fini par trouver la perle
rare un appartement de 24 mètres carrés
à Paris pour un loyer de 810 euros par
mois c'était très compliqué je pense
qu'on a dû déposer en bonne cinquantaine
de dossiers on a appelé une centaine
d'agences pour essayer de trouver
quelque chose et surtout on a eu
quelques visites en fin de compte très
peu de visites comparées au nombre
d'agences qu'on contact pourtant Julie
avait un bon dossier avec deux garants
et un salaire de 2700 euros brut à la
clé faut toujours au moins deux garants
qui ont au moins trois à quatre fois le
montant du loyer nous en tant que
locataire on doit avoir aussi trois fois
environ le montant du loyer comme
salaire et ensuite ça peut aller jusqu'à
des demandes presque un peu lunaires
jusqu'à savoir la date de divorce de mes
parents les locataires sont les
premières victimes de la crise
immobilière dans cette agence d'ici les
Moulineaux la devanture affiche zéro
bien à louer ici aussi
on constate un gel du marché de la
location quand on met un bien sur par
exemple notre petite Century 21 on va
avoir à peu près en une heure de temps
50 email 50 coups de fil et on peut pas
faire visiter l'appartement à 50
personnes entre l'encadrement des loyers
et l'interdiction de louer des passoires
thermiques plusieurs facteurs expliquent
la pénurie de bien allouer il y a une
conjonction de facteurs négatif le
premier c'est que quand les Français
trouvent pas acheter ben ils restent
locataire ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est que vous a pas
échappé que on ne peut plus louer des
passoires énergétiques dans tout ce qui
est g aujourd'hui est censé ne plus être
loué en tout cas ne plus être louable
donc il sorte du parc locatif privé la
troisième raison c'est le non
approvisionnement par l'immobilier neuf
puisque les investisseurs immobiliers
qui achetaient dans le cadre du
défiscalisation bien déverser dans le
marché du logement de la location privée
à certains de logements qui ne déversent
plus le marché locatif est en crise en
Île-de-France le prix des locations
devrait continuer de flamber jusqu'aux
Jeux olympiques de l'été 2024
les causes de cette crise du logement
les solutions potentielles on en débat
avec Henry busy bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes président fondateur de
l'Institut du management des services
immobiliers membres du Conseil national
de l'habitat et membre du Conseil
national de la refondation Sandra aubian
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
présidente du CREDOC le Centre de
recherche pour l'observation et les
conditions de vie pierre Madec bonsoir
bienvenue à vous économiste à l'OFCE
évidemment et mini zappalski éditorise
pour sciences publiques est resté à mes
côtés quelques chiffres pour commencer
sur les ventes immobilières alors c'est
une projection vente attendue pour cette
année 2023 selon la Fédération nationale
de l'immobilier à moins 17% sur un an si
ça se confirme ce serait la plus forte
baisse de volume sur un an depuis la fin
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale Henry
musicazo c'est donc l'une des pires
crises que ce secteur est connu en
France ah oui depuis la prière le
président d'Action Logement disait c'est
la crise du siècle des deux siècles le
20e et le 21e
j'ajoute que les projections de la FNAIM
ont déjà quelques semaines tout porte à
croire que ça sera pire qu'on sera
peut-être double d'accord les
départements de France viennent de faire
une simulation sur la baisse des droits
de mutation à titre onéreux vous savez
que vous payez des droits de mutation et
que c'est le reflet des transactions ils
imaginent au moins 20% de baisse sur
l'année 2023 et moi on parle ils sont
ils sont déjà 16 ou 17% donc voilà et
dans le 9 il faut aussi dire que les
ventes sont en chute libre on est en
moins de 40 - 45 pour les appartements
le collectif et pour les maisons
individuelles donc tous les indicateurs
très clairement sont sombres évidemment
avec c'est pas la seule explication mais
la question de du coût de l'argent des
taux moyen de crédit immobilier on va
d'abord regarder le crédits immobiliers
qu'on était accordés au mois d'août de
cette année ça représente des crédits en
très voyez moins 43,2% sur un an et puis
on va voir ensemble tout moyen des
crédits immobiliers sur 20 ans pareil au
mois d'août 2023 392 quasiment 4%
souvenez-vous décembre 2021 on était à
moins de 1%, ça veut dire que pour un
couple on a regardé la simulation à 4200
euros de revenus il pouvait emprunter
300000 euros en 2021 228000 euros
aujourd'hui Sandra webian qui sont ces
Français qui ne peuvent plus acheter le
logement c'est vraiment la classe
moyenne c'est qui sont les Français non
aujourd'hui on est plutôt sur la classe
aisée en fait là on parle d'une crise
mais il faut aussi relativiser dans le
sens où c'est vrai que les transactions
beaucoup baissées mais on était à un
niveau record de transaction on était à
1 million de transactions aujourd'hui on
a un million on reste à des niveaux qui
sont très élevés donc d'abord pour
tempérer un peu de crise depuis
on regarde un peu plus loin en arrière
c'est ça oui et si on regarde les
niveaux surtout c'est à dire qu'on était
quand même sur un marché immobilier qui
était très florissant et qui ne faisait
que
de progresser donc c'est une sorte de on
a craint pendant longtemps l'éclatement
de la bulle immobilier en fait elle se
dégonfle lentement on pourrait on peut
un peu dire ça comme ça alors en tout
cas les ménages et d'ailleurs c'est ce
que vous avez montré dans votre
reportage qui sont touchés ce sont des
ménages qui ont encore des capacités
d'achat il faut savoir que par exemple
les bas revenus il y a une vingtaine
d'années on avait enfin dans les années
80 pardon on avait 40% des bas revenus
qui étaient propriétaires aujourd'hui
c'est 30%. donc en fait il y a quand
même ça a toujours été plus facile
d'acheter quand on avait des niveaux de
vie élevés mais ça c'est beaucoup
accentué et depuis 20 ans en fait par
exemple il faut être en couple pour
acheter il faut avoir un apport on
s'endette beaucoup plus longtemps donc
il y a tout un tas de leviers qui ont
été mis en place et donc finalement
aujourd'hui on parle de la crise de
l'immobilier mais il y a une crise du
logement en fait qui existe depuis une
vingtaine d'années il y a un effet
domino c'est-à-dire que le coup d'arrêt
des ventes de logement ça a des
conséquences aussi sur le marché de la
location ce qu'on a vu dans notre dans
notre portage ce qui a été dit est très
juste c'est à dire que
la crise du logement elle est là depuis
très longtemps la difficulté de logement
des Français sont là depuis très
longtemps ça fait des années que la
Fondation Abbé Pierre répète qui a des
millions de personnes mal logées ça fait
des années qu'on entend dire que les
étudiants ont beaucoup de mal à accéder
au logement le truc c'est que ça passait
sous les radars
on était sur un équilibre qui était
celui des conditions de crédit très
favorables et donc on est arrivé comme
ça à continuer à avoir des transactions
immobilières à produire du logement
massivement plus que chez nos voisins et
donc ça allait à peu près là le problème
c'est qu'on a un resserrement en très
brutal des conditions de crédit on a des
prix qui s'ajuste très peu des taux à
trois neufs il y en avait il y a pas si
longtemps que ça le problème c'est pas
des taux à 3 9 le problème c'est que
c'est dans un contexte où les prix sont
à un niveau historiquement élevé et que
contrairement propriétaire qui pour
l'instant veulent pas baisser les prix
et que contrairement aux Allemands par
exemple qui ont vu leur prix baisser de
15 à 20% là au cours des quelques
trimestres qui viennent de ce de se
dérouler nous les prix ont plutôt
tendance à se contenir donc c'est là
c'est cette situation de blocage là et
c'est l'attentisme un peu généralisé qui
fait la crise dont on est en train de
parler aujourd'hui je reviens sur le
lien
achat vente et crise de la location
Henri musicazo c'est particulièrement
vrai dans certaines villes il y a des
villes où c'est de plus en plus
difficile de trouver de trouver un
logement location bon déjà le parc
locatif français social HLM ou privé il
est insuffisant il est endémiquement ce
que dit Pierre est vrai il y a un effet
de loupe mis par l'inflation avec tous
ces dérèglements sur des choses qui
préexister et en gros le cancer c'est la
cherté du logement en France charté des
terrains pour construire charté des
logements construits en décalage avec
les revenus des ménages et ça a été
atténué en effet par le crédit facile
mais aujourd'hui on a des pressions
supplémentaires sur ce marché locatif
qui tient à la scadi Charlemagne le
patron de Century 21 un report du marché
de l'accession à la propriété ce qui
sortait vers le haut comme on disait et
qui allait acheter ils peuvent pas donc
ils qui cherche un nouveau logement à
louer une pièce de plus un changement de
localisation
bien sûr ceux qui ont un logement se
mettent aux abris si je puis dire c'est
vrai dans le logement social le taux de
rotation était déjà très faible et il
est en train de s'approcher du zéro et
dans le logement privé et des files
d'attentes alors dans le logement social
qui ont doublé il y a des millions de
demandeurs tout de suite Émilie voulait
intervenir moi je me pose la question
sur un phénomène tout à l'heure vous
avez parlé des couples qui achètent en
couple mais il y a aussi les ex couple
qui commence à se passe c'est à dire
quand il y a une séparation on sait que
c'est compliqué et souvent on reproduit
le couple en deux morceaux c'est à dire
qu'il y a deux appartements donc quand
il y a eu accession comment on fait
est-ce qu'on peut réaccéder à la
propriété pas toujours facile et ça crée
il me semble que c'est un phénomène je
sais pas sociologique ou anthropologique
nouveau qui va créer encore plus de
tension alors ça fait partie des
facteurs qui entretiennent la demande
c'est à dire qu'on vit de plus en plus
célibataire à la fois parce qu'on se
sépare également parce qu'on vit plus
longtemps et donc il y a une demande de
logement qui augmente on a des ménages
de plus en plus petits en fait sur sur
longue période donc d'un côté ça
évidemment ça soutient la demande et de
l'autre côté évidemment c'est beaucoup
plus difficile de porter un logement
avec un seul revenu et donc ça fait
partie aussi des difficultés et
aujourd'hui il y a un tiers des ménages
qui sont déménagent de personnes seules
donc c'est pas du tout anecdotique et ça
explique aussi une partie des
difficultés vous parliez de du secteur
des logements sociaux on va écouter
Bruno arcadippent qui est président
d'Action Logement groupe premier groupe
de logements sociaux en France il était
auditionné ici au Sénat par la
commission des affaires économiques
c'était le 24 mai dernier
aujourd'hui on arrive plus à loger les
gens il faut plus de 8 ans pour avoir un
logement social à Paris comment c'est
possible comment en étant arrivé là
voilà le le
fichier fait ne qui est le fichier des
demandeurs de logements sociaux
il pointait à un million 400000
personnes en 2017 aujourd'hui 2 millions
4 on prend plus de 100 000 personnes par
an
et on veut nous empêcher c'est pas
possible alors on a titré ce débat
crédit immobilier le risque d'une bombe
sociale voudrait vous entendre les uns
et les autres là-dessus peut-être Sandra
ou bien pour pour commencer est-ce que
c'est une menace
alors c'est à dire que ça que ça bascule
en revendication en manifestation en
mouvement social à la mode gilet jaune
alors ce qui est certain c'est que la
question du logement elle est centrale
dans notre société et elle explique
beaucoup des tensions elle explique à la
fois les difficultés par rapport au
pouvoir d'achat puisqu'en fait on a
beaucoup parlé de l'inflation ces
derniers temps mais il y a déjà eu des
périodes dans l'histoire on avait une
inflation qui était plus importante mais
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe c'est qu'il
y a une grande partie du budget qui est
consacrée à se loger et donc il suffit
qu'un tout petit peu d'inflation
n'arrive plus à s'en sortir donc c'est
une difficulté en termes de pouvoir
d'achat c'est une difficulté en termes
de mobilité puisque comme vous le disiez
bah finalement comme notre situation
elle va risque de s'empirer si on
déménage mais on reste dans le même
logement parce que ça sera plus cher en
fait si on déménage donc une société qui
se fige c'est pas très bon pour
l'économie ni pour on va dire les
projets personnels donc est-ce que là on
est arrivé à un point de rupture là ce
qui se passe c'est que c'est des
nouvelles catégories notamment des cas
de plus aisés qui se retrouvent
confrontés à des difficultés qui
concernés en fait des classes moyennes
et des bas revenus donc c'est un peu
plus visible aujourd'hui Pierre Malek
est-ce que on peut imaginer des Français
descendre dans la rue pour parce que
c'est pas tellement je sois pas de de
souvenirs de grande manifestations sur
cette thématique du logement dans notre
histoire commune donc quand on parle de
bombe sociale de quoi on parle de risque
de social je sais pas c'est à dire que
non mais c'est intéressant dans le sens
où la bombe sociale telle qu'on pourrait
l'entendre c'est-à-dire des difficultés
grandissantes de logement on en connaît
une fois de plus depuis des années donc
je suis pas certain quand on interroge
les les Français par exemple il se
déclarent plutôt satisfait de leur
condition de logement c'est-à-dire quand
on met en opposition les enquêtes
d'opinion et les enquêtes de terrain de
l'Insee qui dit il y a tant de millions
de ménages en situation de suroccupation
il y a tant de millions de ménages mal
logé en réalité les Français sont plutôt
plus nombreux à se déclarer c'était
d'ailleurs pour ça que le responsable
politique a du mal à saisir de la
question c'est que les Français se
déclarent plutôt satisfaits de leurs
conditions de logement donc si on leur
dit pendant un an vous allez rester dans
votre logement parce qu'il y a un
attentisme généralisé et vous pourrez
bouger peut-être un peu plus tard c'est
pas certain qu'il descendent dans la rue
par contre il devrait descendre dans la
rue pour interpeller les pouvoirs
publics et pour dire au pouvoir public
qui eux aussi attendent faites quelque
chose parce que si je reprends juste
l'exemple du parc social le parc social
on est en train de se battre aujourd'hui
pour savoir si on va réussir à produire
autant de logements sociaux que l'année
dernière en gros mais du fait de ce qui
a été dit sur la file d'attente dans le
parc social du fait que les gens ne
bougent plus si on produit exactement la
même chose que l'année dernière ce qui
est déjà pas gagné en réalité on produit
pas du tout assez par rapport à la
demande de logement
100 000 personnes de plus par an 2 400
000 personnes qui attendent un logement
social c'est un vrai sujet politique et
pour le coup il faut qu'il y ait une
ambition une volonté politique et donc
du coup il faut interpeller à mon avis
les responsables politiques alors
justement on va en parler des des
réponses politiques à beaucoup de
participants au Conseil national de la
refondation sur ce thème qui avait été
déçu des mesures annoncées après
7 mois de travail notamment c'est le cas
de la sénatrice air des Alpes-Maritimes
Dominique Estrosi ça sonne
tous les acteurs de l'immobilier ont eu
les mêmes réactions mépris désillusions
déception je crois que le Conseil
national de la refondation sur le
logement aura eu le mérite de faire
l'unanimité contre lui il y a plus de
200 personnes qui ont travaillé pendant
7 mois à ce conseil national de la
réfondation tout ça pour ça pour
quelques mesures quelques mesures
techniques quelques mesures courtes
thermistes mais qui n'apportent aucune
réponse à la gravité de la crise du
logement que connaît notre pays et
auxquels sont confrontés les Français et
bien je pense que malheureusement
Emmanuel Macron n'aime pas l'immobilier
le logement n'est pas une priorité pour
ce gouvernement il n'y a aucune ambition
aucune stratégie Henry musicazo je
rappelle que vous êtes membre de ce de
ce CNR est-ce que vous êtes aussi
critique que la sénatrice des
Alpes-Maritimes oui bien sûr et puis
malheureusement on en rajoute moi
j'étais attentif à l'interview récente
du président de la République le mot
logement a pas été prononcé c'est pas un
gadget de prononcer un mot je veux dire
que voilà la sémiologie discours
politique ça fait longtemps qu'on en
fait et c'est majeur le monde n'a pas
été prononcé il a parlé pourtant de
pouvoir d'achat très longuement du
carburant attendez là-dessus hier sur la
planification écologique il y a pas eu
grand chose non plus même chose et puis
surtout faut voir ce budget il est en
retrait de 2 milliards et demi par
rapport au musée du logement par rapport
à celui de 2023 tous les tous les
indices témoignent en effet que ce n'est
pas une priorité aux yeux du président
de la République la bombe sociale
j'ajoute une chose qu'elle est elle est
elle est amorcée elle est amorcée vous
savez on parlait des couples qui se
séparent et bien aujourd'hui il y a des
couples qui se séparent qui prennent
cette décision qui divorce et qui
continue à cohabiter les tensions
sociales c'est ça un enfant qui naît
c'est ça les besoins qui ont déménage
c'est souvent c'est souvent un beau
projet mais c'est aussi contraint je
tente d'ailleurs l'idée que le marché
était très haut en nombre de
transactions et qu'on peut se contenter
de moins j'en suis pas sûr elles étaient
possibles grâce au crédit mais il y
avait un besoin c'est-à-dire que un
enfant qui naît c'est une pièce de plus
un décès c'est le besoin de se replier
un couple qui se sépare un coup se forme
c'est aussi la mobilité ou un nouvel
emploi un nouvel emploi c'est
établi que 19% aujourd'hui des emplois
proposés ne sont pas pris par les
personnes qui le souhaiteraient parce
qu'ils ne trouvent pas le logement à
proximité de l'entreprise et que le
télétravail ne fait pas tout je peux
vous dire comme président d'école que
des étudiants interrompent leur parcours
de formation parce que près de l'école
près de l'université ils trouvent pas le
logement alors ils arrêtent là c'est ils
ont des conditions pour certains ils
vivent dans des campings enfin vous avez
vu tout ça
clairement les les conditions d'une
explosion sociale elles sont là pierre a
raison on ne la sent pas sauf sur
certains territoires allez là où ceux
qui travaillent ne peuvent pas se loger
c'est vrai du Pays Basque c'est mon pays
j'ai un accent qui en témoignent c'est
vrai en Bretagne parce que là il
s'ajoutent à ça le phénomène Airbnb
touristique etc il y a des gens qui
vivent dans un appartement neuf mois de
l'année et qui doivent dormir dans leur
voiture des manifestations quotidiennes
soit elles sont pacifiques soit elles le
sont moins mais on a déjà ça sur les
territoires alors c'est pas national
c'est pas dans toutes les villes de
France mais c'est là alors on va
continuer de parler de la réponse au
gouvernementale on s'intéressant et
Émilie aux nouveaux ministres du
logement vous avez titré ça le nouveau
grand ministre de 6 mesures de mètres
est-ce qu'il sera faire mieux que son
prédécesseur alors c'est sûr que les
styles en tout cas sont très différents
même si les deux ont en commun leur
passé des lieux locaux Clichy-sous-Bois
pour l'ancien Dunkerque pour le nouveau
d'un côté on a la douceur revendiquée
d'Olivier Klein ce sont les mots qu'il a
utilisé lors de sa passation la
passation de pouvoir avec même la larme
à l'oeil de quitter le ministère une
douceur qui l'a peut-être empêché de se
confronter au style bien plus musclé de
ses collègues de Bercy en tout cas
l'ancien ministre qui cumulé le logement
et la ville ce qui n'est pas là le cas
maintenant a eu des difficultés pour
imposer sa patte et afficher quelques
victoires alors bon il y a eu la
prolongation du prêt à taux zéro le PTZ
pour les connaisseurs pour aider les
ménages à acquérir leur logement ils
devaient s'arrêter fin 2023 il est
prolongé jusqu'en 2027 avec quelques
modifications mais au-delà de ça la fin
du dispositif Pinel qui ne semblait pas
être efficace pas de très grande mesure
pour répondre à cette crise dont on
vient de parler construction à la baisse
nombre de ménages en attente d'un
logement y compris sur le parc social
conditions de près de plus en plus
difficile et alors du côté de Patrice
vergrid quel style alors donc ce nouveau
ministre de mettre 02 je rajoute les 0,2
avec un style bien plus affirmé un ton
ferme qui tranche avec celui de son
prédécesseur il affiche déjà la
direction qu'il veut prendre plus de
pouvoir pour les élus locaux notamment
pour tout ce qui est encadrement des
loyers une massification des opérations
de rénovation énergétique des logements
il dit que le faire individuellement
même collectif c'est pas c'est pas
suffisant la question des passoires
thermiques et de leur location
et puis peut-être l'élaboration d'une
loi logement qui deviendrait du coup un
petit peu plus sur la table à l'issue de
ce fameux Conseil national de leur de la
refondation qui atteint un peu déçu on
sent quand même ce ministre qui veut
peser qui souhaite faire avancer les
choses
illustration avec cet extrait il était
interviewé ce matin à Sud Radio
autre exemple sur le crédit aujourd'hui
on est sur les mêmes critères pour
l'investissement locatif quand vous
achetez beau louer ce sont les mêmes
critères pourquoi pourquoi vous avez des
recettes vous avez des loyers c'est un
peu comme une entreprise finalement
louer un logement et on est pourtant sur
les mêmes critères est-ce qu'on peut pas
avoir des critères différents de pour
quelqu'un qui traite pour le oui
j'achète pour louer c'est les mêmes
conditions de crédit meilleur ben non
justement aujourd'hui c'est 35 % et 25
ans oui mais alors je pourrais avoir des
conditions de crédit
ce que c'est cet après-midi c'est
peut-être pas gagné mais en tout cas il
y a la volonté de faciliter justement
les crédits quand on est en location ces
logements et notamment avec des prix
encadrés des loyers encadrés donc il va
falloir voir si cette volonté ce style
suffiront pour apporter des réponses
efficaces un secteur fortement impacté
par les crises actuelles et qui semble
pas être la priorité actuelle premier
test avec le projet de loi de finances
qui va être prochainement présenté on
parle de mesure qui pourrait être
intégrée pour répondre à cette crise du
logement
la limitation des avantages fiscaux
destinés aux locations touristiques on
parlait tout à l'heure de Airbnb pour
remettre des logements sur le marché
l'inversion des plus-values immobilières
en gros c'est pour que les propriétaires
se séparent plutôt de leur bien que ça
tourne en gros ou encore sujet cher donc
à notre nouveau ministre la mise en
place d'un avantage fiscal pour les
ménages qui souhaitent investir dans le
logement en particulier dans ce qu'on
appelle le logement locatif
intermédiaire c'est-à-dire sous
conditions et avec des loyers plafonnés
donc à suivre donc très bientôt pour les
premiers pas de meilleur ministre merci
beaucoup alors il y avait un premier
test effectivement en une musique Cazaux
c'était une réunion à Bercy aujourd'hui
sur cette question de d'assouplissement
dans les conditions de crédit des
banques il en est ressorti quelque chose
ou pas on n'a rien donné Patrice
vergritte qui est un homme pugnace
et habile il va avoir un combat amené
parce que le gouverne la Banque de
France et le ministre de l'économie de
concert
disent que il y a déjà des marges de
manœuvre qui sont proposées aux banques
qui
inutilisable c'est à dire que ils ont le
droit pour 20% de leurs production et à
l'intérieur pour 80% pour les
primo-accédants 20% pour les
investisseurs c'est un cloisonnement
c'est inutilisable et la Banque de
France se dit ça suffit bien et on verra
plus tard donc Patrice Barry quand il
dit qu'on ne prend pas en compte les
loyers des investisseurs il a raison
c'est une absurdité pour les accidents
il faudrait entrer par le reste à vivre
qui les banques savent utiliser c'est à
dire qu'on ne peut pas prêter la même
chose à quelqu'un qui est en train de
vie modeste qui a des faibles revenus on
peut en fait lui le faire confiance on
regarde de manière très microscopique le
client les banques françaises à faire ça
et ne surendette pas les ménages elles
ont un savoir-faire qu'on nous envies
faisons leur confiance les critères
aujourd'hui sont restrictifs le ministre
pour l'instant est battu sur ce sujet
voilà Sandra va bien c'est cette ce
rapport des Français
au logement au crédit il y a quoi il y a
une espèce de de crainte généralisée on
en revient à la question de la des
conséquences sociales de cette crise du
logement est-ce que vous sentez
l'inquiétude grandir sur ces questions
là
moi j'ai l'impression que l'inquiétude
elle était déjà là en fait avant
l'épisode qu'on est en train de vivre
aujourd'hui donc j'ai du mal à dire que
l'inquiétude là où on voit vraiment de
l'inquiétude c'est plutôt sur le sur le
la location par exemple ou effectivement
comme vous l'aviez très bien dit tout à
l'heure il y a un peu quelque chose en
cascade c'est à dire qu'on a du mal à
acheter donc du coup on va louer donc du
coup les dossiers qui sont moins
financés ont plus de mal à louer c'est
là où il y a vraiment de l'inquiétude et
des difficultés et peut-être pour
rebondir par rapport à ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure en fait
effectivement ceux qui sont dans un
logement où ils peuvent attendre mais il
y a tous ceux qui doivent rentrer dans
un logement et notamment les jeunes ou
les foyers qui se séparent ou les
personnes âgées etc donc et c'est là où
oui effectivement il y a une inquiétude
qui grandit votre avis là-dessus pierre
Madec est-ce qu'on peut compter sur le
marché pour se rééquilibrer en quelque
sorte c'est le pari du gouvernement en
tout cas c'est à dire que faut quand
même rappeler que on a aujourd'hui
jamais dépenser aussi peu pour aider la
politique du logement rapporté à la
richesse international on n'a jamais
dépensé aussi peu on a fait des
économies là encore dans le prochain PLF
on annonce un peu moins de 2 milliards
d'euros d'économies budgétaires sur la
politique du logement en supprimant le
dispositif notamment Pinel qui était
très critique mais qui permettait de
sortir du logement enfin je veux dire
des 40 000 ou 50000 pinels qui sortaient
chaque année même si on disait que ils
étaient pas au bon endroit pas pour les
bonnes personnes pas au bon prix le fait
est qu'on sortait 40 ou 50 000 logements
neufs et qui avait bien des gens qui les
occupaient ces logements là le PTZ c'est
pareil on pouvait critiquer le PTN le
prêt à taux zéro pardon
est-ce que c'est le moment quand le
logement neuf traverse une crise
historique je sais pas si la crise du
siècle de deux siècles d'arrêter les
deux seul dispositifs qui soutenaient le
secteur même si on peut être d'accord
sur le diagnostic que c'est un secteur
qui était sous perfusion d'argent public
pendant des années je suis pas perspect
parce que vous lui dites que finalement
on n'a jamais aussi peu dépensé il était
par le passé on a fait beaucoup
d'économies en disant le marché va se
réguler tout seul la preuve c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la machine est cassée le
crédit va mal on solvabilise plus les
acquéreurs ni les locataires ni les
bailleurs sociaux parce qu'on a fait
énormément d'économies donc on demande
aux bailleurs sociaux de produire des
logements alors qu'on a fait des
milliards d'euros d'économies donc ils
arrivent plus à produire des logements
et à les rénover et donc on se retrouve
dans une situation qui est extrêmement
compliquée et c'est un sujet sur lequel
c'est quand même compliqué de faire
mieux avec moi d'argent public on va
parler du de la construction de nos
logements aussi il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de thématiques dans ce débat mais qui
est passionnant et vous propose
d'écouter Olivier Salleron qui est
président de la Fédération française du
bâtiment il publiait quelques mois cette
vidéo sur ces réseaux sociaux
au global les carnets de commandes
garantissent l'activité des prochains
mois mais l'horizon s'assombrit
clairement si aucune mesure efficace
n'est prise rapidement la production du
bâtiment reculera de 7% en volume entre
2022 et 2025 et 135 000 emplois seront
détruits en république d'où sort ce
chiffre comment on peut dire sans
prendre et peut-être qu'il est surestimé
je sais pas mais
il y a quelques mois
Olivier Salleron a parlé de 150 000
emplois détruits emploi direct pour
construire un logement il faut un peu
moins de deux emplois directs voilà pour
être clair
et si on prend les emplois indirects et
le président du pôle habitat FFB
syndicat de constructeur et de
promoteurs à estimer qu'on était entre
200 et 300 000 risques de destruction
d'emplois dans les 24 mois en rajoutant
les emplois indirects en plein direct
un logement ça se gère etc on ne va pas
arriver au plein emploi sans une bonne
santé du logement ça il faut le dire
puisque c'est aussi une intention
louable du président de la République on
ne va pas le faire sans ce secteur qui
est très fortement vous les avez portés
au sein du Conseil national à fondation
c'est quoi c'est un président qui est
sourd aux questions du logement ça
n'intéresse pas comme disait une chose
je suis pas le seul à dire si rien ne
porte en termes sociaux tension sociale
bon les comparaisons internationales les
120 130 000 logements qu'on ne construit
pas cette année c'est 5 milliards de TVA
en moins pour l'État alors moi je me dis
le président Macron en tout cas je pense
qu'il est sensible aux chiffres je pense
que c'est un homme qui a cette culture
là c'est probablement trois ou quatre
milliards de droits de mutation à titre
onéreux de moins pour les collectivités
locales notamment les départements voilà
deux chiffres on est on additionne les
deux on est à 7 8 milliards et pour le
plaisir si je puis dire de réduire de
milliards le budget du logement parce
que on pense que il le faut on va se
priver de rentrer fiscale le logement
coûte 35 milliards par an à l'état ce
budget il va être à 35 milliards et
rapporte 91 milliards voilà donc il me
dit que ce serait de l'argent bien
utilisé si on l'investissait dans ce
secteur il me semble qu'il faut pas
avoir fait une allégation mathématiques
pour comprendre ça alors on va on va il
y a une autre thématique qui est
vraiment très intéressante dans ce débat
sur la crise du logement c'est c'est la
question de la transformation
environnementale la transformation
écologique parce que le secteur du
bâtiment est un gros émetteur de gaz à
effet de serre et donc c'est aussi une
partie de la solution il y a une
mutation qui est en train de se faire on
va en parler tout de suite avec
Stanislas potier qui est président de
l'association BBCA qui représente le
secteur du bâtiment bas carbone alors
déjà on va faire un peu de pédagogie
bonsoir Stanislas Pottier c'est quoi un
bâtiment bas carbone c'est forcément du
bois du béton bas carbone expliquez-nous
en quelques mots
bonsoir Thomas alors si on réfléchit bac
carbone pour
l'immobilier le bâtiment il faut
considérer ce qu'on appelle le cycle de
vie du bâtiment donc comment on le
construit comment on gère comment on le
rénove et puis on en fait quoi quand il
arrive en fin de vie alors c'était
effectivement des matériaux qui sont moi
carbonés qui mettent moins de carbone
quand on les fabrique la façon de mener
un chantier qui est moins carboné
ensuite comment on exploite le
comportement des des
usagers c'est évidemment le tertiaire et
le logement et puis ensuite est-ce que
on recycle on réemploi comment est-ce
qu'on gère la fin d'un bâtiment
l'association qui est née de la volonté
du secteur pour essayer d'avancer sur
les carbonées je vous interrompre pardon
mais peut-être que je suis à côté de la
plaque mais les projets bas carbone est
ce qui coûte forcément plus cher et donc
est-ce qu'ils sont freinés par cette
hausse des taux et par cette crise du
secteur dont on parle
alors il y a plusieurs façons de prendre
la question je pense si on se place du
côté des acteurs du
secteur de l'immobilier c'est-à-dire les
constructeurs les architectes les
promoteurs immobiliers les aménageurs
etc ils ne laissent pas le pied au
contraire dans la conjoncture actuelle
il je dirais qu'ils accélèrent on vient
de tenir un salon de l'immobilier bas
carbone à Paris et vraiment il y avait
une dynamique extrêmement positive mais
comment
nous interrompre
plus compliqué quand on est en duplex
mais comment vous l'expliquez il parie
sur le fait que c'est bâtiments immeuble
de bureau ou
voilà maison maison appartement etc ils
sont plus faciles à revendre parce qu'il
respecteront les nouvelles normes c'est
ça le pari alors ça c'est fondamental
effectivement mais moi je verrai trois
raisons à ça celles que vous venez
d'exposer qui est fondamental à la fois
pour un investisseur institutionnel mais
aussi pour un particulier quand il
achète une maison un appartement c'est
souvent son plus gros actifs donc il a
envie quand même que sa valeur soit
préservée dans le temps qu'il puisse la
transmettre etc mais il y a aussi le
je dirais le fait que on anticipe une
évolution réglementaire et donc aussi
des contraintes qui vont s'alourdir sur
la caractère carbonée ou non des
bâtiments
il y a ce qu'on appelle le confort de
vie et la capacité d'utiliser le
bâtiment que ce soit un logement ou un
bureau potentiellement d'ailleurs les
deux ou les deux successivement et
quelque chose qu'on a tous expérimenté
plus ou moins ce qu'on appelle le
confort d'été on voit bien qu'avec le
changement climatique vous avez des
périodes caniculaires de plus en plus
fortes de plus en plus longue et bien
comment on se préserve de ça il y a des
techniques il y a des techniques
décarbonées pour le faire parce qu'on va
pas installer partout des climatiseurs
et là aussi alors je vais très important
pour continuer à vivre on va merci
beaucoup on va continuer à en parler
tout de suite puisque vous l'avez évoqué
dans dans les bâtiments anciens il y a
la question de la rénovation et de ses
passoires thermiques on en parle tout de
suite grâce à Audrey vêta ce qui va nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau rebonsoir
Audrey la loi climat et résilience qui
interdit progressivement la location de
ces passoires thermique une première
échéance qui va intervenir rapidement la
d2025 le gouvernement envisage de jouer
la montre expliquez-nous alors d'abord
je vous propose de faire un petit rappel
de ce qu'on considère être une passoire
thermique vous commencez par faire un
diagnostic de performance énergétique le
fameux DPE on en entend parler on
regarde les équipements de chaleur
l'isolation les murs les fenêtres la
taille du logement on envoie tout ça
dans un calculateur et puis on obtient
une lettre vous l'avez déjà vu de A à G
a évidemment pour les moins énergivores
j'ai en rouge et ce sera les logements
qu'il ne sera plus possible de louer dès
2025 autant vous dire que c'est demain
pour les logements F ce sera impossible
de les louer dès 2028 potentiellement ne
va pas arranger cette crise du logement
dont on parle non et ça le gouvernement
l'a bien compris alors il tente de
temporiser le ministre du Logement
envisage d'accorder un sursis
énergétique de 3 ans aux propriétaires
prêts à s'engager dans des travaux de
réseau de rénovation c'est assez flou ça
pourrait aussi ne pas suffire car il
faut souvent beaucoup plus de temps pour
que la copropriété se mette d'accord
qu'elle contacte un entrepreneur qu'on
réalise les travaux alors en parallèle
le gouvernement mène ou une réflexion
sur les petits travaux qu'il serait
possible de réaliser pour passer au
moins d'un logement g à un logement F
changer les fenêtres par exemple isoler
de l'intérieur on avance à petit pas car
le sujet est brûlant l'Union des
syndicats immobiliers envisage même de
saisir le Conseil constitutionnel sur ce
sujet pour vérifier que la loi
résilience climat et résilience n'est
pas une atteinte au droit à la propriété
alors là on était sur la question le
droit de louer les logements mais il y a
aussi la question le droit à de vendre
ses logements avec un mauvais DPE oui
l'idée a été mise sur la table par le
chef de l'État en personne c'était il y
a trois semaines lors d'une interview
chez le youtubeur Hugo travers interdire
la vente de logements non rénové pour
forcer les propriétaires à engager ces
fameuses rénovations vous l'imaginez ça
a créé un vent de panique sur le marché
d'autant que ce qu'on considère être des
passoires thermiques ça représente
actuellement 20% des logements vendus le
tout en pleine crise et sur ce sujet le
gouvernement marche un peu sur des œufs
écoutez ce qu'on disait Franck Riester
le ministre ministre des Relations avec
le Parlement c'était hier écoutez ça
fait partie des des possibilités mais
pour l'instant c'est pas acté c'est pas
acté alors où je vous parle oui oui
c'est pas que ça doit changer dans la
journée mais on verra bien de la
République
alors hier ça n'était pas acté ce matin
ça a changé écouter le ministre du
Logement
c'est parfois depuis que je suis
ministre du Logement je découvre parfois
des trucs sur les réseaux sociaux des
débats il n'a jamais été question
dans les yeux il n'a jamais été question
j'aime bien ça
de vendre pas d'interdire à la vente
pardon les logements FG mais au
contraire au contraire il faut
encourager les mutations
alors j'ai appelé le ministère du
Logement faut avoir le fin mot de
l'histoire qui confirme la position du
ministre ce matin pas d'interdiction
l'objectif c'est de flécher les aides
pour soutenir les propriétaires les
inciter à rénover au moment de la vente
voilà qui est acté pour l'instant en
tout cas merci beaucoup Audrey c'est
toujours très bien d'aller à la source
de l'information merci Pierre avec Loris
c'est quoi de voir certains
propriétaires retirer leur logement du
marché parce que ils ont pas les moyens
où ils veulent pas faire ses travaux
pour améliorer leur lettre des PE déjà
il y a un consensus pour dire que c'est
pas normal que des ménages locataires
vivent dans des passeurs thermiques bien
sûr donc c'est pas normal que des gens
mettent en location des passeurs
thermiques bon je pense
il faut lutter contre pour cette raison
et aussi pour accomplir les objectifs de
bien évidemment de baisse de nos
émissions dans un contexte une fois de
plus où on a un marché de la location
privée qui se contracte ou les gens
mettent de moins en moins leur logement
en location pour tout un tas de raisons
Airbnb des raisons fiscales des raisons
aussi de parents de la réforme de la
fiscalité du capital qui disait aux gens
d'investissaient pas dans le logement
investi investissez sur les marchés
financiers parce que le logement est un
bien productif mais tout ça donc les
gens mettent de moins en moins leur
logement sur le marché et on veut en
plus interdire les mises en location de
passe par thermique sans contrepartie
pour les propriétaires ça pose quand
même question donc c'est une bonne
mesure oui il faut aider il faut
l'accompagner il faut évidemment
accompagner les bailleurs et il faut
aussi accompagner les propriétaires
occupants il y a une vraie nécessité de
rénovation faut quand même le dire il y
a beaucoup de passoires thermiques en
France on parlait du confort d'été mais
il y a aussi juste le confort d'hiver la
précarité énergétique est extrêmement
importante donc il y a un besoin de
rénovation qui est massif mais sans
moyen public oui on y arrivera et alors
d'accord mais sauf que on est quand même
un niveau de de dette assez astronomique
dans ce pays et là depuis le début on
dit il faut se souvenir tel secteur il
faut peut-être faire des choix mais là
c'est de l'investissement ben là c'est
de l'investissement dans la transition
environnementale je dis pas qu'il faut
pas non mais ça a l'air d'être dans le
carnet de route du gouvernement qui veut
investir massivement il y a des efforts
massifs a été fait sur ma prime rénove
notamment il semblerait que le
dispositif qui fonctionne très bien ça
il faut le dire c'est un grand pas qu'on
a fait pour être mieux cibler pour être
bon voilà il y a des choses à faire avec
déjà les outils existants mais c'est pas
de la dépense publique c'est pas des
aides au logement on a compris que le
gouvernement voulait pas les augmenter
c'est pas des subventions versées au
bailleur sociaux c'est de
l'investissement pour la transition
environnementale et donc c'est important
de mettre les moyens et beaucoup de
moyens pour rénover et qu'on ait un parc
de logement de bonne qualité Sandra va
bien il y a aussi une dimension c'est
qu'il y a il y a quand même beaucoup de
propriétaires pour en France c'est à
dire que alors c'est peut-être difficile
à évaluer moi j'avais eu un chiffre de 2
millions d'euros avec un interlocuteur
sur une autre chaîne de 2 millions de
pardon 2 millions de propriétaires
pauvres là en cherchant cet après-midi
on était plutôt un million un million
d'eux donc je sais pas si vous avez des
chiffres là-dessus mais il y a des
Français qui tout simplement n'ont pas
les moyens de faire ces travaux il y en
a c'est vrai mais il y en a pas beaucoup
par rapport à l'ensemble des ménages et
par rapport à l'ensemble des ménages
propriétaires par contre pour ceux qui
sont dans cette situation c'est très
compliqué d'ailleurs ça pose la question
de l'accession à la propriété du fait
qu'on a beaucoup pendant longtemps
soutenu l'idée que la France devait
devenir une France de propriétaire et
c'est vrai est-ce qu'il faut vraiment
rester dans une phrase de propriétaire
parce que on sait aussi que à la fois
être propriétaire c'est une sécurité par
rapport à l'avenir c'est du patrimoine
par rapport à la retraite et donc c'est
vrai que dans le contexte actuel ça peut
paraître intéressant mais c'est aussi un
peu moins de mobilité on sait que les
locataire sont plus mobiles donc par
rapport à l'emploi un peu plus de
fluidité voilà donc aujourd'hui on a
vendu un peu l'idée que tout le monde
pouvait devenir propriétaire et donc les
gens aussi s'endettent parce que s'ils
ne deviennent pas propriétaire c'est un
peu comme un certain nombre d'autres
comportements ils ont le sentiment
d'être sexueux de pas avoir réussi leur
vie et d'ailleurs parmi les gilets
jaunes il y avait beaucoup de
propriétaires de propriétaires qui
s'étaient éloignés des centres-villes
qui étaient vraiment au taquet si je
puis dire de leur budget et donc il y a
cette question de finalement est-ce que
l'accession à la propriété c'est ce qui
doit être le modèle dominant en
Allemagne qu'on compare souvent à la
France ils ont beaucoup plus de
locataires par exemple et ils sont pas
forcément plus malheureux la révolution
culturelle Émilie je trouve qu'il y a
une déconnexion c'est ça qui est
flagrant dans les mesures qui sont
annoncées pas très réfléchies sur ben
voilà c'est comme les chaudières ou fluo
le c'est comme la pompe à chaleur alors
allez-y on va équiper ah ben non
finalement on interdit pas la chaudière
au gaz parce que ça va être ça va être
terrible il y a plein de gens qui vont
pas pouvoir le faire une déconnexion
entre ce qui est proposé pour laisser le
temps au secteur éventuellement des de
la géothermie des pompes des pompes à
chaleur etc d'être prêt à remplacer
il y a des velléités donc des mesures
qui sont annoncées et puis on se rend
compte que la réalité que ça soit des
propriétaires pauvres qui peuvent pas
faire donc on recule moi ce que je
trouve inquiétant c'est que le logement
c'est vraiment un cas d'école c'est un
modèle pour ce qu'on va devoir faire en
termes de transition écologique
c'est-à-dire quel financement ça va être
pour les transports ça va être pareil
comment on fait pour financer ça en
épargnant les plus modestes en demandant
peut-être un effort au plus riche et
c'est ça qui est en question et pour
l'instant le gouvernement ne veut pas du
tout aborder cette cette phase il veut
que ça soit de l'investissement mais que
ça rapporte tout de suite mais sans
investir ou en tout cas sans réfléchir
exactement comment on va faire ce calcul
qui va être très compliqué à faire alors
il y a effectivement le dispositif m'a
prime rénov dont vous parliez 2,5
milliards d'euros de budget pour cette
année 2023 pour des Français quel que
soit leur revenu à rénover leur logement
réduire leur consommation d'énergie et
donc les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre Stanislas potier je reviens vers
vous vous êtes resté
à nous écouter est-ce qu'il y a
suffisamment d'artisans formés
labellisé d'une certaine façon pour
mener tous ces travaux de rénovation
thermique
je si je peux revenir quelques secondes
sur le financement il y a un rapport
très intéressant de l'Institut de la
finance durable qui a été remis à Bruno
Le Maire avant l'été qui fait d'ailleurs
le même constat que le rapport Pisani
Ferriss sur le coup de la transition
écologique et notamment dans le secteur
de l'immobilier mais qui dit aussi que
on a suffisamment des pagnes pour
financer ce coup et donc il y a un enjeu
très très important à la fois de de
direction de l'épargne disponible je
pars par exemple le livret A le LTDS le
livret de développement durable
l'assurance vie vers les besoins du
secteur du logement et du bâtiment de
façon plus générale aujourd'hui et puis
le second enjeu est effectivement
l'apport public là où il faut le mettre
pour déclencher la décision
d'investissement que ce soit un
investissement public ou un
investissement privé
qui part dans un terrain qui nous reste
deux minutes un mot clé quel mot
confiance réponse rapide à la question
sur le les artisans la formation des
artisans
il faut il faut former il faut former
pas uniquement les artisans et y compris
dans les grands groupes y compris chez
Bouygues par exemple les compagnons du
minorange aujourd'hui se forment c'était
les grands spécialistes quand même du
bétonnage et se forment aujourd'hui aux
nouvelles techniques au nouveau
matériaux aux nouvelles façons de mener
les chantiers et il y a un enjeu très
fort mais formidable aussi parce que
c'est de l'emploi non délocalisable
c'est de l'emploi extrêmement utile
c'est des compétences nouvelles et donc
moi l'impression que à travers les BCA
c'est que le système et le secteur 6 mai
mais il faut accélérer ok merci beaucoup
c'était très intéressant de vous avoir à
vous le mot de la conclusion Henri
musicazote peut-être sur ce finalement
il y a tellement d'objectifs cumulés et
puis alors là si on rentre dans le dans
le concret on se dit ok on veut rénover
tant de passoire thermique sauf qu'il y
a pas les artisans pour le faire c'est
ça le constat aujourd'hui 600 000
entreprises en bâtiment moins de 10%
d'entre elles ont le label reconnu
garant de l'environnement alors c'est
quoi ce label il permet notamment
d'accéder aux aides si vous ne recourez
pas une telle entreprise vous n'êtes pas
les aides 10% on était à 15% il y a un
an ça veut dire qu'effectivement on a un
vrai problème de compétences de
formation et on est très loin du compte
très loin du compte ensuite il y a la
question aussi du financement j'entends
qu'il y a les aides nous nous voulons
pas la face les ménages vont devoir oui
puiser dans leur épargne s'ils annonc et
recourir au crédit les banques ne sont
pas au rendez-vous il y a deux banques
aujourd'hui qui savent prêter aux
copropriété parce qu'on appelle des prés
collectifs toutes les autres ce sont
détournés de ce marché dans la
profondeur je vous laisse juger et de
l'ordre de 200 milliards d'euros dans
les copropriétés pour les remettre à
niveau
de rénovation thermique pour qu'elle
soit vraiment efficace faut que ça soit
un projet global même si le ministre a
raison de dire on va regarder mieux de
tout faire d'euros et bien les banques
aujourd'hui ne s'y intéressent pas
le Bruno Le Maire devrait
incontestablement les réunir et obtenir
d'elle qu'elle soit beaucoup plus
engagée et enfin on la question de la
fiabilité des diagnostic on en a pas
parlé mais il faut fiabiliser ces
diagnostics on part aujourd'hui sur des
bases qui sont chancelantes pour
certains logements et quand on sait les
conséquences d'un logement qui est fiché
FG ou même ou même eux effectivement il
faut que les travaux voilà il faut quand
même que ce soit fiable merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat je vous dis à bientôt sur Public
Sénat fin de cette émission rendez-vous
demain 18h22 heures et puis dans la
matinale Oriane m'ont signé reçoit Hervé
Marseille le président du groupe
centriste au Sénat belle soirée
[Musique]